what about now can you hear us now Oh
shucky ducky I think they can hear us
now okay which I might the Bob yes it's
called the big old building and that's
what bo b stands for and they have like
dance club and restaurant on one level
and then the club is on another level
yeah beautiful club cool people you
should have a really good time it's
gonna be hot as balls I'm sure it will
be again to those of you who couldn't
hear us on Ustream you didn't we haven't
gotten into the meat of it yet talking
shop talking shit we did our we did our
ads amazon.com Spotify right go to our
website click on the banner is
everything good now sounds good sound
now yes so now wait I have a date to
plug to well I have two replug because
we had oh you love your butthole I'm
going to be in Grand Rapids at doctor
grins come and see me sorry Floyd
Mayweather is gonna be there other
people are gonna be there he's joined in
there
yes she's getting out of jail just to
come and see me it's returning what is
your do you good well June 28th through
30th I'm gonna be in Dallas Texas y'all
Speer steers and queers and albeit
hyenas it's called hyenas in Dallas
Tejas June 28th through 30th this is my
first time doing Dallas yeah I've done
was I some awful meth place it was a
really shitty place yeah somewhere
there's always only toothless meth
people Medford nono Medford's in Oregon
I should I can't remember no no where
well anyways Dallas come see me please
say hello
the mommies you guys make our night when
you come out and you support it's the
only thing that keeps this going
no I'm just excited I farted on your lap
remember yeah and then the first week in
July I'm gonna be at the Dayton funny
one Dayton Oh me and Katt Williams
what's up you not gonna be with Katt
Williams this but he'll probably be
there cuz he's from there
is he from live in Dayton I'm a Dayton
motherfucker yeah yeah absolutely
then I'll plug my next but hold date all
right after that July I think it's four
through eight I will be at the Palisades
levity live okay state in New York okay
buddy live in the Palisades by the way
New York you should let people know
because there's a lot of New York City
meows that it's not that far it is about
40 minutes from the city so yeah if you
really want to go see your mommy
Christina live great that's the closest
you're gonna get for a while so I don't
have any New York for this right here so
that's a really good chance I'm saying
okay now can we see you saying can't
wait all right and if you want to look
for future dates a lot of people were
like when you come into this do ya go to
your mom's house there's a tab for so
tight right now they're way up let's do
this man fucking sorry black mother god
damn shit
welcome to your mom's house
I don't even know what's happening I
know I don't understand why what's he
yelling for he's very upset that the
people in the video game news then he's
playing are not performing up to his
standard it's like one of those games
are you playing with other people in
different parts of the world
no he just you know he just played he's
playing a basketball game and he's just
you know playing against like his son oh
and the the the players just aren't
playing yeah you know they're like he's
shooting in the game yeah and then
they're not responding they're not
making baskets it's a problem he needs
to really talk about it he's so upset it
I don't blame him like I get video games
yeah I know I used to do when I came
when I had that the graveyard shift yeah
when we first started dating my life
changed I would come home and the way
that I would wind down
as that would play n-c-double-a yeah the
college football game and when it was
like I'm on a great coming off the
graveyard shift it's like seven eight
and one I would take the remote control
and if like if like you know I threw an
interception on my I would throw that
shit this is so hard against the wall
the Brian who'd be getting up for work
we're like coming because everything
alright broke that wall over there
better you throwing that than throwing
Brian across this is your dad dad why
are you so angry yeah I get this way
over like puzzle bobble though Oh like
you imagine being a kid that's why kids
are so fired up now cuz they're playing
these games and they're all riled up
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah everyone has
fuckin a DD I mean yeah I get it though
he's something else man oh I'm gonna
birth again really what's going on did
you start eating burger
Oh wish that was somebody we knew mmm
alright so let's catch up man yeah
buddies
where was you were in where were you it
was in man-friend disco Manfred disco at
yeah it was a cool week get a cool show
you were with uh what's that girl oh my
god I had the best it was me
Jessica curse on yeah she's funny
fucking hilarious why look her up if you
guys are into she's just fucking amazing
yeah and Gina yeah sure a she's it's
pronounced yeah she she she's Nigerian
she's a black girl from London yeah and
she has a cool fucking axe that she's
really funny
he's but they're fantastic she's really
funny they were so much fun and it was a
great week and and it was my Smurf day
oh yeah thank you guys for tweeting me
everybody tweeted her only I'm only 23
so that was happy 23rd birthday and your
husband took you out yes spoiled you yes
you gifts many gifts you got me a proper
luggage so I don't look like a hobo
that's actual adult luggage not hobo if
I could it's a really bad tweet like
twine and fucking pillows are you found
in the parking lot I just feel guilty
spending money on like on shit like I
literally guys I'll have a backpack that
I dragged its got like a thing with
wheelies and then I'll go with the whole
female stranger oh my god what was that
oh that was from the ads you're working
on no that's the ads that pop up our
poor listeners half the year yeah but
they can I haven't downloaded it I'm
sorry but they could download the ad
blocker and I guess I didn't do it on
this computer okay so that's so funny
we've got genital hurt sorry about that
and I'm sorry I don't look can somebody
somebody out there has to know that if
if I paid for a Ustream producer Pro oh
fuck here we go again
why do I hate this whole process it
makes me upset what part of the process
that these fucking ads keep coming up in
but don't you hear me trying to address
that no I do it's upsetting me to see
you upset
yeah I'm not mad at you no I know but
I'm trying to say like if somebody
fucking knows like how I haven't how do
you
Podcast to shoot without the app I don't
know what else to do I know jeans like
we've paid for like the highest level
there's only one other level we can go
to and it's an additional three hundred
and fifty dollars oh my god that's
banana so I'll pay for it I will pay for
it
if you're telling me that that means
there's no more ads though I don't know
they don't explain you and we have to
ask well blue band obviously doesn't ask
him blue band what should we do buddy
what he's not very bright dude that's
how I feel about Ustream yeah I feel
that way exactly I'm sorry party genes
on an exciting note today though I
bought my own Sriracha hot sauce that
I'll be putting on my Vietnamese fall
later today it's pretty exciting my own
supply which means I'm gonna get severe
ring sting tomorrow I'm gonna push the
boundaries in my ass I bought some salad
to not be as fat do you feel you've been
saying that you've been family I feel
fatter I've been working out a lot you
work out tremendo
better what do you think's going on I
don't know I don't know I mean I need to
change my diet obviously yeah I
definitely feel good I'm sorry babe yeah
don't feel good hey you know what you
called me today why don't we tell our
listeners what you what you called me
you said I drink like goat you have a
billy goat mouth and yeah you said I
have goat lips goat lips that's right
Suzie Tommy and I do the go yeah I don't
look like that all the time
yeah but then when you when you when you
drink a bottle you don't know how to how
to put it to lips like a person so you
just pour it and then whatever gets in
your mouth gets in there and the rest
goes all over that is not out goat and
you chew on yet
the end of it that's not how Billy Billy
Goats they go like like a hamster like
on a hamster no no you know what you
have what dog tits whatever you have six
pairs of dog tits you know one of my
goals good dog gives birth yeah and they
feed off two four six eight you have
eight dog nipples that's what your dog
kids look like I will feed any puppy
that wants to feed off of one of my nips
I wish you could nurse puppies I wish I
could do it nothing would make me
happier well what else is new what
happened what happened to you I was in
where was I I was in Toledo I've been
there
I love Toledo your favorite City no
here's why don't because I was there
like in January like a year ago it was
like freezing freezing freezing cold and
all I could do was just run from the
hotel to the club yeah I couldn't do
anything now we had great weather with
good shows fun I mean there's definitely
I would say one or two shows where I was
like oh all of you got free tickets yeah
when they're like somebody just handed
me a pass so to come in here I was gonna
go to TGI Fridays but I decided to come
here yeah yeah so much fun yeah but then
there was there was good shows fun shows
met cool people some mommies came out
there yeah very special mommies who came
to a few shows Dom and ELISA who I
enjoyed meeting so much and they brought
their dad on Father's Day oh that's cool
really cool so shout-out to you guys and
I got Christina is going to sign your
special special gift and she's gonna
we're gonna send it back to you that's
cool
I want to apologize to Cobbs mommies I
didn't mean people after shows I wasn't
feeling very good oh really
yeah I didn't I just was trying to get
through stuff so if you guys came out to
Cobbs and I didn't say anything after my
apologies I usually meet people but I
was not thank you oh thank you I tell
you it did happen it cause I'll tell you
guys I'll tell you guys top secret so
there is a girl in Carl
that put the make on me oh she was a
softball player surprise surprise
softball players girls softball players
are usually gay mm-hmm okay
and at the time she wasn't she was not
gay but anyway yeah so so um we were
hanging out sophomore year and she was
totally like hey do you want to get some
whiskey let's go and drink whiskey and I
was like okay and then it was thought we
had a totally drunk and then she was
like come back to my dorm room we can
just hang out and listen to music your
dorms so far just come over and and then
the next thing you know it turns into
like 2:00 in the morning and she's like
oh you don't want to go back to your
dorm take a block away you should say it
I was like okay and then she totally put
the make on me man you guys French city
really girl French city but I wasn't
into it
I was hot so anyway I tell the story on
stage on Friday in San Francisco just
randomly I'm like just tell a story when
I lived here and when I and the crowds
into it like it was a fun there's no
lesbians in the crowd cuz yeah you know
I think some of the comics on my bill
were gay so yeah I was like yeah I'm
kind of gay too and I told the story
yeah yeah and the girl the fucking girl
shows up on Saturday night that's so gay
seen her since he didn't tell her no
nothing nothing she just happened to be
like on Facebook and saw the post and I
was like get the fuck out here I just
told the story about how you accosted me
yeah molested me yeah and now she's
happy she has a girlfriend she's like
got a cool life it's great so it's great
okay but it was very bizarre like to
mention that person and then have them
you just show up so she did the thing
though basically she did what guys do
yeah yeah you don't want to go there
yeah yeah and let's cuddle oh and that's
what she's like just sleep here well it
didn't go below the belt there really no
just smoochies
I remember this kisses uncomfortable
kisses for me you were taller I had a
good girl that I was putting the moves
on in college and as it's an escalating
right
building she's like oh just what like
she goes I should tell you something and
I was like what she goes I don't suck
dick and I was like yeah cool
thanks for throwing that out there right
like look as a rule yes just no just
just like I'm not into doing that and
I'm like alright you kind of just killed
the whole did you expect her to suck
your dick well I mean I was I was it was
right against the corner of her mouth
she was like I just I know I don't suck
dick all right well at least give it a
kiss actually is that when you're spoke
when are you supposed to tell people
that kind of stuff like I don't know but
then I was like this fucking flea flu
where here's the thing like if she's
gonna take that why I'm not gonna do you
any favors you know like I was I was
planning on taking care of you oh I see
it's just preemptively um believe me I'm
not gonna suck it and then I'm like
alright well I'm not gonna yeah you
shouldn't chew the forest forest and
then at that point it's like well
there's only one other thing to do right
so do I just shove it in yeah you know
that's what she wanted just shove it in
there shove it in I guess yeah
well it's kind of like that girl in
Detroit Airport when she was like these
chips are 450 you still want him yeah
and it was like a preamp yeah yeah like
hey this is gonna suck you know what it
gave me a very like right now no and
she's probably not a very good thank you
not a very giving person yeah as a whole
yeah I kind of want to stay away from
those those types really I don't that
can do that I still you know I still
smashed it I beat it up and tossed it
out but you know I tell you this
I remember what she looked like though
so what did she look like
like shorter shorter yeah that's it
that's what I remember
that's it shorter you do you realize you
have no recollection of people that
you've actually had intercourse with
like you don't know yeah crazy to me I
know I know the people I know everybody
I've kissed yeah no I don't lesbian
included that's so disgusting hope your
wiener rots off not why I'm married to
you after I die after you die
yeah we're rats off that's not maybe so
so let's talk about Oh on my way to this
is we were talking about this on my way
to Toledo on a flight I had I flew first
to I think we're gonna fly to I flew to
a major airport Chicago okay and then um
little hair and then I connected to
Toledo on a regional jet which I fucking
hate them
yeah but anyways you can't put your
fucking carry-on above you they make it
so it's one of those things where it has
like I don't know it's like in 40 seats
in it or something yeah so I'm in the
for the first four seats there's only
one one row so it's like literally one
two three four and then behind us it's
to spine does that make sense so the guy
I know I'm just bringing it down make
sure everything so this this guy I
suppose we board I sit down and I take
out the book I'm reading and I go
already and I hear the guy in front of
me he's like so uh you're a flight
attendant huh and the girl it's like a
cute like probably recent graduate of
college who's a flight attendant she's
like yeah he's like you like it and he's
probably he's probably like 65 between
65 and 70 right maybe maybe he's a
little maybe 68 and she's like yeah he's
like I've been everywhere
I've traveled I've traveled all over the
place and she's like oh yeah and she's
doing the thing you should as like
you're basically Anna service job and
you're like I'm the person she's almost
like a you know like we had a hotel and
the person engages you that's when I
cocktail waitress you need to talk to
old perverts when I was 20 and you got a
you got a so but he starts doing this
thing and I realized as I'm listening to
him that like of all the things I don't
want and I don't want to end up being
this guy which is the older guy who's
who's basically hitting on a younger
girl but disguising it as I'm just
having a conversation yeah yeah and his
game is so weak and like it's
offensively bad you know I mean so like
everything everything that she said he
would go cool oh cool isn't that cool
and so she's a gap and he's like so what
are your parents like that's radical
yeah and she's like they're really nice
yeah we hang out like we went to a
concert and that cool in that cool yeah
yeah but when she mentioned the band oh
fuck it was like she mentioned the band
she goes she says that this all shows
you know like Death Cab for Cutie he's
like sure I want to be like you don't
know who that is
you've never you fucking liar and he's
like sure yeah she goes we went we had a
great time he goes that's cool that's
cool yeah I took my family to say it was
just the coolest it was like that's his
one word he had his one word just
fucking old dude who's just trying to
connect with somebody I tell you my dad
hits on young girls okay he's good at it
he doesn't and here's the key to doing
it is don't be anybody other than
yourself right
like if you're a dad boner you just just
do you bro you know what I mean like
just be that's that is new at all it's
key actually that's the key at any age
so yeah just just be you and the less
like you're trying it's always the
better yeah I haven't feel weird like
using Twitter I feel like I'm too old
to feel like hey guys if I get caught
it's like it feels the same no yeah I
feel fucking want you know we feel like
Sean Connery like some kinda cool like
when they put them in with urban kids
he's trying to connect so he's like I'm
just connecting with you I'm speaking
your language I win this this movie came
out I've been thinking about that since
like 1996 like whenever it came out
because it was such a fucking lame scene
yeah we're like with a home where they
they have like the older white guy
paired with like the hip urban kid this
story's been told somebody
yeah it's Michelle Pfeiffer was shot and
when Sean Connery did it I was like no
dude yeah you're the man now don't know
the man now dog it's the worst it makes
me so happy it's so yes and this is so
stupid of me sorry guys did you love
that I've been thinking about it since
96 I think and you guys whenever that
gives that one of those things where you
walked out of the theater and you're
just saying it over and over to you know
I think I saw it at home no no I didn't
I'm sorry no it was in the preview it
was in the trailer and I'm like did they
just put that in the fucking like that's
a selling point for this piece of shit
yeah it is amazing it's amazing who
fucking what does this piece of shit
movie called it's called you're the man
now don't like yeah Good Will Hunting
no man no you're the man now dog you're
the man
so it doesn't that's the that's the
equivalent awful that's the guy on my
flight oh cool
yeah I got a jersey on my ipod riprap
wha
is it a jigger is that what he is oh my
god yeah that's embarrassing and I had
to sit through this
oh here's the other thing is the flight
that connection flight is like our inch
hour and 30 minutes something like that
yeah from from Chicago Toledo he never
left her alone
that's he didn't shut the fuck up I had
to I thought I could just I was like
you're gonna make me get up and put my
fucking noise-canceling headphones on
just to back out your babble I did when
we landed and I took him off he was like
that is cool that is it's like it never
fucking stopped he couldn't shut the
fuck up
absolutely when it sucks for her because
she's in the position entertains
gracious yeah I mean gracious yeah she
could have been like I can't talk
anymore
which I really wish you would well what
I learned to do in my older years is um
now I do this I didn't learn this until
I was about 30 is whenever you go in
public glass is on people make fun of ya
cuz I wear big glasses mm-hmm and I keep
my fucking eyes forward I don't talk to
anybody because that's exactly what
happens to you maybe not now that I'm
older but when you're younger every
douche bag is like come on man like I'm
not gonna fuck you on this plane not
that I'm so fantastic I'm just saying
that guys will if you're you know of a
certain age you're just fuckin trying to
nail you it's a it's I know and that's
the saying that's the I'm saying like
the guy I don't want to be when I'm 65
doing a shitty flirt fuckin thing with a
22 year old flight attendant I don't
want to be no no I hope you're still
married to me and that you're not I know
I'm saying at least I used to I do it
like a little more casually yeah you
know I used to have bosses give me
another fuck yeah
that's how you do it yeah just like hey
cute
you know you pinch her but when she
walks by you know you you lick your
finger put it up her skirt or something
classy is what I'm saying
you know what I love well I will say
today we had relations Jesus no and it
was the first time I'd been with a white
guy for how long has it been since
you've been with a white man I just have
sex every Puerto Rican guy on the road a
lot of black dudes I got fingered by an
Asian guy on Monday
you did get stalked by an Asian guy
you'd have to throw that detail and I
would have just left it at that
why don't tell them that was the doctor
it was the guy at the fun place that you
guys yeah the chef at the fun place it
was very loving only one finger though I
know you're disappointed mm-hmm anyways
did it turn you on because that's a hot
experience right doctor is always hot
yeah it's very erotic it's a high why
they rata sighs that shit man I don't
know how on pornography right I actually
my gynecologist she told me one time
that she had a lesbian couple come in
and they were like oh do you fantasize
about the proctologist ever no no no he
gives you like a killer rectal exam and
you just blow low no and actually I've
never had like a sexy doctor or any
really not they're usually hot I know
like when you make good no but I'm
saying like I've never had an attractive
which is you know but I I have had that
every time I've had like a physical and
they've been like drop your shorts
however small my penis can get it's it's
never been sure it's never been slightly
fluffed it's always been like it's
always been like I've wanted to make an
excuse like I wanted yeah I've wanted to
say just so you know it gets bigger like
the doctors who obviously don't care I
just want to be like do you think they
do because here's no there's no note I
didn't know this
I have one time went to a party at a
really wealthy doctors house in Florida
I ecologist and it was big party going
on and then I could hey can I ask you
something we're at the bar that's at in
his house and he's like yeah let me go
how do you separate like as a
gynecologist you know like your mind
from you know like the sexual right to
when it's like you're doing a medical
exam right and he said he's like oh
pussy's pussy right that's all he said
and I was like got it meaning there is
no separation he still sees he still
sees you as a sexual imagining getting
I'm in your clam and I wish I could get
in there a little more you see this is
why I go to a female gynecologist this
this doctor I saw was a urologist mm-hm
and I didn't know he was gonna do that
to me I didn't expect that I would have
a finger on my couch that day mm-hmm and
Monday was my birthday right
and I was like I so I didn't clean up
downstairs like I was I would came off
the road it had been like you know like
a week and I've been with you so I was
like I'm just gonna let this grow and
then yeah I literally said to him I'm
like dude I'm sorry like I if I don't
know and you're gonna be down there I
would have cleaned it up and he laughed
and stuff but it was terrible what
that's just funny that you told him like
I would have cleaned it I'm sorry if I
knew I had visitors but I didn't it was
gonna fucking I know I know fingerblast
of course of course you're the man now
dog I would have said the key Majan if
you had said that while he's finger he's
like you're gonna feel a little pressure
he puts his finger I'd be pretty
fantastic
I think that they do they have to
sexualize you because I always look at
my doctors physical appearance and judge
them yeah today really
of course you don't let you don't judge
the physical appearance of your doctors
yeah of course I don't think I've ever
had the doctor where I've been like
what's going on man no not like that
super hungover
n double acp is going to come after us
no well speaking of heroes I think it's
time right is it time for you buddy stop
dog hey buddy top dog hey buddy top top
top dog couldn't be any better
so as you guys know a few weeks ago I
took a trip with TD what top dog and
what did you guys go - we went to
Portland Maine and we had a great time
we drove around we saw we went to
Kennebunkport Oh were they the Bush
family Bush compound right right right
that was really really cute I didn't
even know that yes that's how the story
yeah so it's embarrassing but ya know
when I was in high school I knew the the
one of the we know an extension of the
anheuser-busch family and I dated a girl
in that family and anyways still friends
with the with their with them and so and
I was main ID I sent her a picture I go
it's the Bush compound in Kennebunkport
and then I called her and I was like did
you see that picture and she was like
yeah I goes that's the Bush compound she
goes could have been all yours man could
had all that beer and I was like what
he's like if you had stayed with her
that could be your place and I was like
no that's a different Bush family babe
thought about the former president yeah
I never heard a can debug port that's
pretty I know that Oprah interviewed
Bush somewhere nice and then I saw the
picture I'm like oh that's where Oprah
interviewed him yeah it's pretty well
known I didn't know it was a stupid name
for something nice it's pretty good
isn't called something so stupid I don't
know why it's called that but I know
that it is called that I don't know
everything I can't know everything it is
funny I know what I was talking to who
was I talking to about it I was talking
it could have been Odessa Texas that's
where I had the held gig Odessa sorry
this is from earlier today when we were
together I forgot that that you were
growling at me I recorded it so yeah a
lot of people know that but you know
what's funny is how well-read you are
like you can you basically are so well
read only sure that nobody cares about
right like what happened no but like but
then like you don't know stuff like that
what Kennebunkport would be associated
with like which president would you
associate with like Crawford Texas no
idea how about Chicago Chicago a
president yeah Osama bin Laden there you
go that's right right Obama was from
there wasn't he mmm there you go
I knew that here's the thing I don't
give a shit about politics we all talk
about no fucking care
and not only that
that was that my pussy be yankin yeah
yeah nine that nobody said that word in
my family growing up Kennebunkport like
we don't know I know you have to be a
news junkie to know about you know if
you're not into the news and you would
not I get my news from the cool you know
what happened like the Attorney General
today nah
it's interesting whatever listen I do
you know what Heidegger's you know
design is it's if you if you hold your
head down and you don't pick it up and
you're never gonna see this guy okay I
listen to you know philosophy podcasts
but I just current events to me are
cyclical I understand pointless it bore
me another guy did something shitty to
somebody else
yeah well it's all the same so we're
excited for this though when I hung out
last week when I like shit talk because
it's no fun it's always good it's always
good talking about we gave you a little
taste we talked to I was there right
then when top dog shit his pants you saw
he didn't listen last week's episode you
need to go back and yeah because I was
there moments after it happened and I
recorded the play-by-play of what
happened and it was pretty fantastic so
rare it's like watching here that's a
that is a rare gift to have that happen
so anyways amazing it's amazing nobody
gets to see that and there's some more
top dog gold for you here right now the
next day I recorded some more
conversation with him so let's just get
into it would you say okay we'll get
right into it right now here is some
more TD the other day you texted me we
didn't get to talk you texted me that
you had a long shit which is different
than a big shit because long shits curl
around the toilet yes right yeah totally
different did that happen to you the
other day yeah you know you started
shitting and it just felt like it was
gonna go on forever really
there was no plop yeah you know he's
just kind of and then of course when I
was done I checked it out and it just
I call it up there like a snake the
snake basically yeah
do you try to win those when those come
really long do you try to hold on to not
break no did you try to keep yourself in
break and get to see how long it you
know I'm talking about I do that all the
time I know if I I can clinch it and
yeah snap it off yeah or maybe I could
just I go for that I can do I swear to
god Tommy
yeah I did a foot long and then another
half foot like a really sure yeah when I
was in Florida oh wow it was amazing
yeah but I know what he's talking about
if you don't hear it plop it almost
concerns you and then when you look in
the bowl you're like oh this is amazing
oh yeah yeah that's pretty cool
okay what's the longest you've ever
turded um I may have had a you know
probably a fifteen inch or before
fifteen in a single yeah single bound
yeah you know I just kept going I
figured I'd be done any second but it
just kept coming
yeah yeah a while ago we were in the car
and it was you me and mom and you said
we were in the car you go I have talking
about you know you smell you smell your
farts you put your hand down there I
think you smell them okay it's funny is
that you him tonight right then yeah and
he goes no I don't do that and I just
looked at when I was like huh and I
think part of him was just doing an
automatic denial but then when I
reminded him that we had and it's in a
previous episode you remember the
episode do it right but the episode
where I go he goes I have six different
smelled like he was talking about it
yeah and that's why I was like huh cuz
he denied it I was like what what do you
mean
I know my smell okay but then as we were
talking about that
you said I basically have six different
types of smells right so what like I
mean could you kind of break down what
they are that what are the different
ones that there's one smelled you know
it's gonna be a hard wooden when it
comes out you know what self tells you
that yeah there's another one you Marg
lend me basically kind of a diary of a
hard one
Oh meaning like the consistency you know
there's others that are kind of in
between yeah there's one they're just
kind of the normal smell which means
you're fine gastrointestinal any unusual
episodes so you know what's coming oh
yeah really throw my own built-in radar
system okay then do you just like to
know what's coming basically I think oh
yeah I suppose you to be prepared yeah
that's my motto be prepared be prepared
is your motto Marine mom do you have
people ask me to ask you do you
recommend you have a favorite type of
toilet paper yeah I really do you know
in fact when I go to the grocery store I
get basically top-of-the-line Charmin
with the alloy with aloe vera two
lotions by the way that's another bad
thing is like yeah there's at least
thirty words I can think of that he
doesn't know how to pronounce
yeah for years yeah and your dad's
American born yes and for like 30 years
he's mispronounce them and every time I
go you mean like a lo he's like yeah my
dad says hey there's Joe trade there's
Joe traders Joe yeah and then he goes I
need your advices like he pluralized
things that's a foreign thing but he's a
foreigner that's a foreign thing ya know
top dog always is like the ally thing
very know and he also says PDO fire
that's so weird
yeah he's like see this guy right in the
news is PDO file I'm like pedophile he's
like yeah I'm like how can you not
fuckin say it right maybe yeah maybe he
hasn't seen the word written there
I don't know man if ya built it yeah you
like that that's my favorite brand you
know
Sherman is a great it's consistent
toilet paper yeah you have to take that
into account too is what you suddenly
got to go I mean you gotta go you want
to go into a place it carries good you
know generally you go to the Ritz
Carlton's Four Seasons all the top-line
hotels carry good toilet paper yeah
right then when you go to some of the
motels and stuff it's really bad
yeah motels cleaning this gas station
yeah I really try to avoid going on an
airplane okay oh yeah oh yeah me too but
you know in some of the but it's getting
but you know getting better I was on a
cruise ship wants it really bad
in fact I'd recommend it to a friend
take a couple of his own rolls
yeah you've told me you that - yeah
really
that might be a good you know just
philosophy in life raise it on role does
he do that yeah he does yeah on cruise
ships yeah I bring a killer in couple
rolls on his own are you fucking kidding
me
no that's bananas they've been on so
many cruises that he's ya know so easily
hey make sure you pack a couple rolls
keep my hole soft yep
you know what yeah so you really you
think that through huh oh you know it's
just like some people it's like you know
when yet when you laying out your
wardrobe for shoes and yeah you also got
a plan plan you know you know it comes
out do you bring the rules with you I
did on the last cruise alone you didn't
I brought a backup for all just one yeah
I just bought one for emergencies you
know and because an act tight which is
really good - yeah you're on cruise ship
you kiss you paper for your nose yeah
much softer well see they don't really
like it when you use that yeah but it's
ten times how does he know they don't
like it when you use it I don't know
maybe cuz you're not supposed to flush
that kind on a grill maybe it's because
he went through like a hundred tissues
and they're like hey why do we keep
replaced well I was gonna suggest cuz I
often in place of toilet paper yeah I
use Kleenex
yeah of course it's nice and so nice so
why can't they make
toilet paper as soft as Kleenex why
don't we ask the real questions on now
that's a real talk question shit buddy
that's a really good question I don't
know you know what they should do make
like a premium premium top-of-the-line
toilet paper that feels like silk on
your asshole
even though it's like twenty dollars
like a fun thing happens I mean when you
do pay for it yeah yeah but nothing
worse than a rough toilet leak in the
dorms like in college I remember they
gave us one ply and I petitioned to wear
that green shit that you get sometimes
you know like brain like the the fucking
it's good for the earth oh fuck all that
like trader traders Joe yeah
yes recycles hair it's fuckin sandpaper
man like the military gives you bad Toby
but it really absolutely that's a good
tip it's a pro tip is it pro Jeff yeah
do you have are you still using the
countertop wipes to wipe oh yeah yeah
yeah no that that really I mean that
kills you know you gotta this is there's
bacteria everywhere today
sure you know you read about this on
computer laptop door handles yeah
everything so I've kind of bought into
this whole thing that you gotta fight
fire fight back okay you're fighting
back I'm fighting back and this I don't
feel like that's too strong kills
everything yeah people are scared to use
it there's no such thing as too strong
when it comes to the bugs okay the bugs
yeah I think killing bacteria stuff like
that give it its you're it's for like
countertops and like grease you know you
think how do people underestimate how
tough their behinds are really yeah you
sit on them all day long yeah yeah
that's good enough for the prom me rant
yeah it's gotta be good enough for your
body and some people take it up the ass
regularly you know so that's pretty
strong he's using like Clorox brand yeah
we went to we went to the CVS I was sick
guy I had a cold I went to CVS and I
Hey and it was the Clorox like it was
like extra strength like kills you know
it said like industrial-strength and I
go is this the stuff you use to wipe
your ass and he looked in he goes yeah
that's it buddy you gotta be shitting me
I was like that you can use it he was
like great and then he just walked away
it's bleach he doesn't want to hear it
he doesn't want to hear what you know
he's gonna hurt that's holy Lord your
butthole right you can't wipe your
asshole with a bleach Kleenex
yeah kills 99.9% of all the germs sure
it does in in like in chemical plants
and the other thing it's strong you
don't have to worry about punching your
finger through that stuff either oh
that's so really your hand is safe you
know it's kind of like you know having
real protection
I'm sure you got it man yesterday you
really had an episode this is the day
after the incident the incident the 2012
incident was good yes I didn't make it I
mean I was you know it was just ugly I
had to go and you know I misread the
sign in the hotel yeah and had to go
down the stairs and I was squeezing the
cheeks going down the stairs yeah and
then I went into one of these places you
know where they you know you're rushed
in but it's one of these handicap stalls
and it's an extra five feet before you
get to them yeah it is feisty too far
five feet too far that's my favorite I
gotta go I gotta play that again
I'd be too far you know you rushed in
but it's one of these handicap stalls
that's an extra five feet before you get
to them yeah
and it's five feet too far five feet too
far yeah yeah yeah track your underwear
let's throw out my underwear take a
shower head take a shower yeah put those
pants away put the pants a night wearing
those pants the rest of the trip that's
for sure that's the trend with stains in
it but you know
you can sum there something is
definitely hey we were talking about
this the other day what describe oh wait
is your mom gonna wash those khakis that
he's shit in um does your mom do the
laundry yeah
yeah so she's gonna smell but he claims
it doesn't smell well there was I didn't
smell them there was no there was no
stain least those shit wearing them
that's one of those phantom things like
where you fucking shit and then you
don't see the evidence until lately yeah
you know what I mean like we well I
tried to convince him not because he was
like they're fine and I was like I
wouldn't wear those you just shit in
them yeah you may not see it at first
yeah it's like when you shit and then
you you have like the neverending wipe
and then later you wipe like two hours
later it's like a full wipe again oh
this is oh this is the part we got it
like there's more to come
I asked him about I don't want to tell
you I asked him about dating no yes and
like picking up on chicks and he give us
some really good advice but here's the
big announcement we've been holding on
to are we doing this now let's do it
right now why not then we're just giving
time all right man stuff right now so
this is our break to tell you we talked
about it for a while people a lot of it
it was you know listeners were
suggesting this and asking about it and
we finally did it
we have it's so good it's so good we
have a Top Dawg t-shirt that is it's the
best one we've ever come up with ever
it's if you go to your mom's house
podcast.com and you go to the store it's
the first one you'll see now it's it's
done indie like but like the Top Gun
logo right like Top Gun the movie right
but it's top dog and above it it says
your mom's house podcast calm underneath
it it says wipe down but it's it's done
so well yeah we had
the same designer ash Otaki in Florida
did the design she did an amazing job
and we've just put it up some people
found it before we announced and ordered
it already it's it's gonna be bananas
yes thank you crazy
wait but here's the thing that's really
cool it's the kind of design where
because this was really important I
asked for this specifically where you
don't feel the design I feel like this
shirt yeah yeah
like the ink is on top right this is
it's called um I forget what they what
they call it but it's it's where the
logo and the shirt are one like the
Ingres bled into the shirt so it's high
quality it's it looks awesome and you
can come you can order it now it'll ship
in two weeks
and I'm just we're just I can't fucking
wait man I can't wait to get mine we
actually today we're repping shirts you
have desk wash I'm wearing a kingfish
shirt and yeah anyways that was uh this
is the top dog this is it this this is
the official shirt of the podcast it's
so rad I can't have to get it just to
ship him one
oh he's gonna die he's going to die
there's no idea how loved he is he has
no idea I showed I showed him I showed
him I asked you guys to tweet Father's
Day things to him and attacked I would
do the screen grab and send it to him he
was a sneak buddy people this is
phenomenal
yeah so pre-order get your shirt order
now your mama's house podcast I can't
fucking wait go to the store and check
it out it's rat it's fuckin dope a shirt
and I'm so excited about it so now some
more top dog let's see where we are with
this we've been working month
oh I saw a what was left of a Vietcong
guy that would garden this is about
dating a bomb good cop we talked about
Julian I want to talk to the dating
stuff really does look like oh really oh
yes it's almost unrecognizable so that's
an instant kill that's well you never
know what hit e yeah what about a little
water that looked more painful and you
see stuff like that well you know with
the things that are hurt
very often aren't the worst ones oh
right don't kill right right yeah
interesting you know so when you get we
step on the mind you don't feel anything
it's all so fast yeah I've heard guys
say that the only thing it really hurts
or hurts the most are belly wound social
bad yeah bleeding out and stuff yeah
happily yeah belly ones but you have
flak jackets so that protects you from
grenades but if you're gonna take a 47
rounds right but I'm saying blame
bleeding out from your gut yeah that's
the worst yeah
switching topics here one of the lot of
the guys asked you know our single when
you were single and see a lady you want
to approach so good kind of wine do you
use on her say one of these guys he's a
attractive woman what do you say to her
he's about just he's about to dig it's
cool everybody I can't even imagine well
I I would be you know I would walk over
to her mm-hmm and usually I say could I
get you a great can I get you a drink
sorry that get you drank what if she
already has the drinks you still say
that I would kind of wait so the other
drink was just about done she's kind of
waited out do a little recon okay
check your radar around the room kind of
check out the body language see if
there's another guy involved see how
she's drinking the drink it's all about
timing
what if you're in a non drinking
scenario let's say you're at the post
office do you still say can I get you a
drink
well let's see what did I do
it isn't even address that it was a long
time ago
waitresses I used to work on waitresses
when we're serving you yeah really what
would you say well you try to be
charming I said you know I really like
the way you feel about my make laughs
like glass you fill up my glass just so
could you get rid of the glasses for me
to really catch him off guard
it gets so much better you have no idea
he's about to shut he's about to tell
you what got him the most chicks that's
his big line he's not even your the man
that's even worse than you know dogs
come on it's just not there's no game to
it I know
Yeah right there okay you know you know
they know you're you're kind of hitting
on right yeah you sit there and give
watcher do that God you can do that well
and they don't think you're a creep when
you do this now and so that makes some
kind of comment you know and just the
banter and you can tell if they're
interested because of you know how
waiters they can do their little circle
yeah they come back over and and they
kind of talk right my line used to be
like but you got a meaty cunt hey what
are you doing after this that's how we
met right yeah in a meaty count on you
Christine Kenny ask him
where you're from how long he worked
here was intersector cetera and then you
know you said well why don't you give me
your phone number I'll write it down on
the napkin mm-hmm
sometimes it would but one time the girl
said to me give me your phone number
I gave her my name she called didn't
call she called but the best ones the
best system of all mm-hmm there you go
bank tellers bank tellers ah just farted
no showers I'm gonna go in oh shit okay
what's that smell mean what's coming
yeah oh that means that some of this
stuff I've had on this trip that much I
had today that didn't digest well yeah
that's coming out it's coming out later
tonight drive away really tomorrow
morning probably it will start off today
with that's really bad I'll be kind of
dizzy tell the bank teller was he laying
down yeah and it was like I can hear him
like strike bank tellers ladies that is
wait wait till you hear how in-depth
this is this is not just some
run-of-the-mill oh here's something kind
of this is like well-thought-out very
calculated here we go guys you're gonna
start banking ready take your notepad
out get your pen ready
so you know we're all gonna pay the
price for that one okay so he's a bank
tellers bank tellers yeah so what you do
is you go to the bank and you crush you
got no survey you know the attractive
bank teller and you make your deposit
you kind of just banter low but to see
if there's any back banter you know
mm-hmm
so then what you do is then go back the
following week you would time your
deposit if their case or is aligned just
with her oh I got you okay and so if
like people are going to different
tellers you try to make sure you go to
her absolutely okay so now what you do
is you say to her
look how much fucking money I have well
if they're into you they not wet day you
come in to make devises
mm-hmm so you could come in the
following week and she's got the red
dress on you know she likes this is it
he's right did you hear this but that's
why your mom thinks he's gonna murder
her because he's methodical he variable
yeah he's talking about a three minimum
three-week operation Wow two or three
week kind of up okay so then what you do
when you make the deposit you're right
yeah and if not fucking kill you
Wow so here's again to recap it was you
you you scoped out the joint
yeah you find a cutie then you go you
see if there's chemistry Wow the next
week same time you go in you make a
comment about something that she's
wearing and and how much you'd like it
which and then you go back the third
week at the same time if she's wearing
that seeing the same thing again you
know that she did it basically because
she thought you were coming in right no
no any comments I really liked the dress
right so remember the interaction from
last time right that no that's no no the
second time you point out what you let I
really like those area yeah or that
dress I haven't seen you wear that it's
really beautiful you look great in blah
blah and then the third week if she's
wearing it again she's wearing it
because she's trying to impress you wait
is it good it gets better it gets better
and then you write on the last time you
write you want to have lunch dinner on
the back of your deposit slip which
probably will scare her at first because
you're probably
is this a no that's people right give me
all your money on this killer because
they're robbing really oh yeah
how often did you use this trip well my
single days I used it every place event
every place you banked and you were a
serial bank teller dater
yeah what I did was yeah I had multiple
accounts at multiple banks are you
serious yeah wait this was your system
my modus operandi you had multiple
accounts at multiple BIOS sure how many
banks we don't know doctor three banks
in your single days single is yeah yeah
so you like in your mid-20s late 20s
early mid to mid-twenties mid 20s yeah
good 27 and how many dates would you say
this got you oh I would say probably
we're gonna probably get six different
really yeah and there were these all end
up being girlfriends or no but now I
would say the one often became a
girlfriend for you no one's really
thanked oh yeah and then a couple other
ones just went out a few times yeah you
went out a few times kind of sorbate you
know beat it up and tossed it out you
know even here oh this is one yeah your
hell are you now 64 64 yeah back in your
single days okay right so we're talking
you know over 30 years ago how when you
went out with and you were you were you
know you had intimate relations with a
woman
what type of protection did you guys use
back then oh we didn't we just took her
took her chances I'm gonna say I want to
save the rest of that for next time
because we've been at this allowed Wow
this is pre-aids
yeah yeah yes the worst you could get
back then was syphilis or a baby right
yeah yeah that's exactly right that is a
baby was the Morgans more of the concern
to it didn't give a fuck though no you
just drop a loads on every Bank
housing one in America I think there's
somebody at like Chase or Citibank now
that that's a brother you know I think
that his theory is spot on because bank
tellers is they're usually he said
college-educated right they're usually
young good-lookin broads good together
good-looking chicks work at bay like our
Wells Fargo yeah I remember when he does
I told the story he took a photo of one
of the girls and their friend she's
actually a friend of mine yeah like
she's come out to my shows no that's
girl you took a photograph of but she's
wonderfully beautiful put together so
top dog new word hunt that dog nowhere
to hunt he was he was giving you
knowledge he was telling you how to do
it right not so crazy when you think
about it not so crazy Wow top dog I'd
like to hear more about his single life
before Charo because I know that when
we're all together at home it's probably
not a good time to talk about that stuff
when she's around but that's the best
time to bring up that stuff for her
reaction because to get her you know
what I was actually planning on doing
when we go home for Christmas we have to
do Christmas oh definitely a Christmas
wish mom sounds Christmas special of
just but not just that and I want to put
the headphones on her and play her now
play her this stuff of my dad talking
about his farts no not the dating
because I was gonna say you're trying to
kill your dinner and he's gonna get
murdered
no but the fart stuff yeah and and then
have a mic then have a recorder going so
that when she's listening to him talk
about his farts she just goes absolutely
apeshit
yeah I feel really because it it's funny
disgusting is disgusting they done the
way why is he be disgusting so that is
um will give you more more so fucking
good table dog stuff next that was
really good audio he really gave he
shared a live made that before and I've
known the dog now for a few years
there's a more there's more coming more
and we'll get it so that is our that is
our show for this week thank you for
joining us
everybody joined us live thank you for
joining us live and we'll try to do live
again next week I'm in town you're in
Tuesday earlier in the week that's blue
blue band thank you guys again